episode 13. the gang is closing in on
their goal of making the antibiotics but
they need alcohol
it just so happens that the grand bao is
offering alcohol as a part of the prize
so now they have all the more reason to
win the gramp out
to increase the odds of them winning
everyone joins including senku
after almost half a year since arriving
at the village with kohaku
senku is finally allowed to set foot in
the village to take part in the grand
bao
when he meets ruri she recognizes his
name even though they have never met
and she asks him about his surname which
no one uses in this time
she collapses before he can answer but
he says that they're gonna have a long
talk once everything is settled
magma's henchman mantle recognizes that
kohaku's strength is still a problem
because she was the one that defeated
magma in the last grand bout
to counter how op she is he kidnaps
suica and ties her to a tree
he then approaches them giving them the
story that suica is drowning
this forces kohaku to go since she is
the fastest but also compromises their
last line of defense against magma over
to suica who manages to get free from
her bindings and makes it to the grand
bout just in time to see kinra who is
facing off against magma in the first
fight
he was holding his own pretty well
thanks to his training but he too
also has bad eyesight like suica and
this causes him to start to lose ground
zuika can tell that his vision is the
problem so she throws him her mask with
the lenses in it allowing him to see
clearly in the fight
turns out that he was always a lot
stronger than magma he could just never
see
putting him at a disadvantage but now
that they're on even terms magma doesn't
stand a chance
ye episode 14. even though it looks like
the fight is over magma convinces kin
road to talk to the ref about the helmet
being allowed or not and once his back
is turned magma attacks him from behind
defeating him with a cheap shot what's
the [ __ ] point of having a ref if
you're gonna let [ __ ] like this slide so
keener gets eliminated everybody's like
oh okay yup seems good mantle then
throws his match to ensure that kohaku
can't make it back in time which gets
her disqualified but she doesn't really
care she's just happy to see that suica
is okay
we get some filler fights that don't
really mean anything but then it comes
down to chrome vs magma
chrome is obviously in over his head and
getting beaten down pretty badly he gets
the idea to use the glass and sweetest
helmet that was destroyed when magma
attacked genre from behind to start a
fire
he needs time for the fire to start
which cues the return of genn who magma
is shocked to see because he thought he
had killed him genn convinces him that
he's alive due to his magic
and he cursed magma so that if he moves
his heart will explode but the curse
will only last one minute
this [ __ ] buys enough time for
chrome to start the fire and knock magma
out of the ring making him the winner in
the most
anti-climactic fight ever episode 15.
now that magma is out of the running
there are only three contestants left
with senku going against guiner
and the winner of that will go against
chrome in the finals
the original plan was for everybody to
work together to get chrome to win this
is because rory and chrome are clearly
thirsty as [ __ ] for each other but rory
doesn't want to come off as too
desperate so she says that she would
marry anybody who won
genre doesn't pick up on the connection
between chrome and rory so he decides
that hey if she's going to marry anybody
i'm going to put my name in for
nomination
he decides to go all out on senku gets
hit in the nuts and concedes
senkou tries forfeiting to chrome in the
finals but he is still in bad shape from
his fight with magma so he falls
unconscious making
senku the winner of the grand out he
gets the rights to marry rory and then
immediately divorces her because he was
just after the alcohol they work round
the clock to finish up their soul for a
drug and after administering it to rory
they learn that she has
pneumonia the sulfur drug proves to be
effective against it and ruri
is finally healthy again as a reward
senku is declared chief of the village
which is actually named ishigami village
the same surname as senku upon hearing
this ruri reveals that she has known
about senku ever since she was a child
episode 16. rory tells him that she knew
about his name because of stories that
she had heard from her mother
the story was about senku's father
biakuya ishigami and how he became an
astronaut with the help of senku he goes
into space with cosmonaut shamil
volkov and an american singer lillian
weinberg
arriving at the international space
station they meet with connie dalia and
yakov
well in space the phenomenon that
petrified everybody occurs
giving them a front row view of the
event and the aftermath from live
streams
they come to the conclusion that they're
the only six humans left and they need
to get back to earth
episode 17. biakiya makes some big brain
plays and determines that the event had
originated from south america
shamil lilian and connie makes their way
back to earth but wind up in the middle
of the ocean forcing the other three to
go back in order to save them buyakia
takes a boat out to them
and the six of them manage to survive
living on a nearby island
they live happy lives for the most part
even having kids but it couldn't last
forever as pneumonia struck them as well
one by one they all started to die so
biakya writes
the hundred tales which is a collection
of stories and facts to pass down to
their descendants for happier lives and
in hopes that senku would come across
them
jump back on up to the present where
rory and senko go to the cemetery where
biakia and all the others had been
buried
when they returned to the village they
have a party going on and genn spoils
the mood by saying that sukasa
is coming and bringing an army which
prompts an eager response from
senku episode 18. they don't have any
time to prepare as tsukasa's men
and their leader hyoga launch an attack
on the village
quinro sends genre to alert the others
while he holds him off but now that he's
back to having bad vision he loses dinro
is faced with having to cut down the
bridge and sacrifice kinro to protect
the village but he can't bring himself
to do it
senku creates a guise to make it seem as
though they've already figured out how
to make guns
and this lie is enough to deter them in
fear of being shot
they rethink their plan and decide that
all they need to do is attack when there
is a storm that way the guns won't work
only three days pass before a storm
rolls in marking the chance for their
second assault on the village
the village was hard at work in those
three days though and with senku's
guidance they managed to form katanas to
fight back against the enemy's primitive
arsenal
having the upper hand with their new
weapons they managed to break all of the
spears using the katanas
hyoga is still putting up a fight but
genn had found an opportunity
to sabotage yoga's spear so it breaks in
the middle of the fighting
without weapons the assailants are
forced to retreat a second time and
gen's alliance to the kingdom of science
is now known to sukasa and his men yep
episode
19. we get a short and rather pointless
flashback of tsukasa waking up hyoga
after searching for him because he's a
strong fighter but is still weaker than
sukasa
we then learned that the attack really
wasn't meant to work it was just a
distraction so that hyoga's right-hand
woman homura could set
all the huts in the village on fire this
leaves all of the villagers out in the
open
and vulnerable to a possible attack some
of hyoga's men
are looking for an opportunity to take a
hostage and they target suica
she makes a run for it hoping to protect
the other villagers and they end up near
the pool of sulfuric acid
gohaku manages to get to suica as the
wind blows toxic gas
toward them getting a mask on her and
protecting themselves
this leaves hyoge and his men stranded
in a tree while the others make their
escape he wants to see if the air below
is actually toxic so he sacrifices three
of the grunts finding out that it is
toxic and they're gonna be stuck there
for a bit they know that the longer
they wait the more men sukasa will
recruit with the revival fluid so senku
plans to make a phone in order to help
in the fight
episode 20. most of this episode is the
village working together under their new
chiefs orders to make the phone
at first they need wires so they make a
cotton candy machine
and test it with sugar to work out the
imperfections knowing that homora is
likely spying on them to keep track of
their progress
and make sure they didn't flee good guy
senku decides to leave her some cotton
candy
as well they make gears to help with the
labor and start making as much wiring as
they can
chrome has also been working on a
project of his own and with the help of
kasiki they accidentally create a
waterwheel surprising and pleasing senku
yey episode 21 senku continues making
leaps in their means of production
using the water wheel to relieve a lot
of the work strain on the others
he then goes on to make the light bulb
and decorates a tree with a bunch of
them so that they could celebrate
christmas
after that he works with casa key to
make a vacuum tube but the problem is
that they can't find a mineral that can
withstand the heat
as everybody gets together to celebrate
the first sunrise of the new year
a rock that suika had found starts to
glow
this makes senku realize that tungsten
the most heat resistant metal in the
world is what they need to make a vacuum
tube work
so magma chrome and senku volunteer
themselves to go on a mission and
collect more of it
episode 22. well and in mind looking for
tungsten the three end up in a
predicament when magma and senku fall
into a sinkhole leaving them stranded
at first it looked like magma was trying
to kill senko by pushing him into the
hole but later on it's revealed that he
was really just trying to save him well
stuck together they both agree that
there are roles that they both need to
fill and they put their differences
behind them at least until sukasa is
dealt with
there's a small body of water nearby and
krung comes up with the idea to fill the
hole with the water until it reaches
high enough for them to crawl out
they both manage to make it out and mine
a deposit of various minerals before
heading back to the village
when they arrive senko is greeted with a
gift that the others had been working on
over the days that they were gone genn
uses his knowledge from the old world to
direct
everybody on how to build an observatory
as a gift for senku on his birthday
episode 23 is them building the phone
yeah episode 24. everyone is super
excited that they succeeded in finishing
the phone
until they find out that they need to
make another one in order for it to work
despite this they can still test it
across wires confirming that it's
working properly
rory and senku end up talking about one
of the hundred tails which was
actually a hint from byakuya the hint
leads them to his gravestone where they
find a glass record preserved inside
byakuya recorded a message onto it so
senko constructs a phonograph to play
the message back
he talks about how he knows it's senku
listening and the gist of it is an
implication that he loves him to leave
things on a high note we get a song
recording from
lillian since she was a famous singer
everyone is moved by the music and senku
says that it's not just music but there
were all kinds of entertainment and he
wants to work towards bringing all of it
back
first things first though the kingdom of
science has to figure out a way to bring
down the sukasa
empire this all starts with getting back
into contact with their moles on the
inside taiju
and usuria i'm gonna be doing the future
seasons and you can find out the left
side whenever i'm finished with it or
you can check out all the dr stone
recaps in the playlist on the right side
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros
is outros